rencontrer Norman Babcock sa famille est un
peu ennuyeuse ne pouvez-vous pas être comme les autres
enfants votre agent je pensais que vous aviez dit des enfants de
mon âge trop occupés par le vol à l'étalage et Joyride
cet ami est un peu non et il a un
cadeau matin qui est plutôt étrange j'ai
besoin de voir  vous les gars, homme de paix,
voyez-vous tout le temps, ouais,
génial,
vous savez, je suis un vieux clochard bizarre et puant qui
vit en haut de la colline, je lui demandais, je
parie que personne ne vous a parlé de la malédiction de la sorcière,
ont-ils pu sauver sa ville  ce fantôme
va se réveiller
un regarde les trucs dont tu as besoin d'un peu d'
aide je t'ai eu et beaucoup pas mentalement
cet été est tellement normand
quand les zombies frappent à
sept heures d'accord personne n'en a écrit
j'ai accroché le canard ne compte que le vrai héros
J'ai compris que personne ne l'avait arrêté